das hier ist das vierte Video der
siebenteiligen Interviewserie mit den
Teilnehmern von Seven vs wild Staffel 2
viel Spaß mit dem Interview von
wildkader Joris
Staffel 2 war deutlich extremer der
Standort hat sich geändert und es gab
unterschiedlich viele Gegenstände für
die verschiedenen Teilnehmer wie hast du
dich auf das ganze vorbereitet okay
meine Vorbereitung war primär
theoretisch tatsächlich also ich habe
viel gelesen über die Tierwelt über die
Pflanzenwelt um halt vor Ort zum einen
viel zeigen zu können und zum anderen
halt auch Nutzpflanzen zu finden denn
wenn du weißt welche Pflanzen essbar
sind dann ist es vor Ort ein großer
Vorteil falls du keinen Feierabend
bekommst ja wie habe ich mich noch
vorbereitet natürlich noch auf dem
YouTube-Videos geguckt Dokus und
sonstiges Zeug also war alles mögliche
dabei ich war auch mal auf dem Acker und
im Wald habe ein bisschen was an
shelterbau geübt aber nicht wirklich
viel ich habe auch tatsächlich hier mein
allererstes richtiges Alter gebaut
also primär theoretisch tatsächlich ja
im Vergleich zu Staffel 1 gab es aber
noch eine große Änderung wie war der
Drop auf Tag für dich ja also der Morgen
war wirklich besonders weil ich habe
relativ gut geschlafen tatsächlich das
erste Mal seit Tagen ja es war ein
bisschen so wie so ein Film sage ich mal
also es war ganz ganz komisch und ich
weiß nicht wie es beschreiben soll aber
es war einfach geil also dieses Feeling
wie du deine Bus steigst und dann fährst
du zum Flughafen fliegst du mit dem
Flughafen Flughafen rum fliegst du mit
dem Flugzeug rum es ist geil und auch
der Job auf natürlich vom Heli war
absolut atemberaubend ich habe so
entscheidend hat so Spaß gemacht war
Bombe meckern nach dem Job auf fliegen
die Helis von dir weg und du bist zum
ersten Mal richtig alleine wie war das
für dich und was waren deine ersten
Schritte also tatsächlich war das
allererste was ich gemacht habe von
links nach rechts zu checken was kann
ich alles nutzen was kann ich wie nutzen
was gibt es vor Ort auch an Müll an
Pflanzen und Tieren was kann ich
verwerten was vielleicht nicht welche
Möglichkeiten gibt mir das Ganze so dass
ich erstmal groben Überblick habe dann
war mein Plan 20 Minuten den Strand
abzusuchen das habe ich auch getan
ja lief alles super und die Isolation
die damit einhergehen die war
tatsächlich ziemlich easy also ich hatte
damit weniger ein Problem alleine zu
sein tatsächlich
ja es war natürlich eine extrem neue
Situation und das erste Mal dass es so
wirklich in dieser Situation war aber so
ja war war also war eigentlich geil ich
sag es ist einfach mal Ruhe und man hat
Zeit für sich selbst man kann sich auf
Dinge konzentrieren Projekte im Kopf
Arbeit abarbeiten das ist geil okay
Isolation also kein riesen Problem für
dich wie bist du aber mit den
Tropenstürmen umgegangen die am Tag drei
angefangen haben der Donner ist bis ins
Knochen Knochenmark durch das war
wirklich geisteskrank also kann man
nicht anders sagen das war wirklich
wirklich krass und
ja es war eine extrem geile Situation
irgendwie weil man genau gewusst hat
okay jetzt geht's richtig los jetzt
werde ich richtig rangenommen wird der
Natur und es war halt auch irgendwo halt
gut so das hat wirklich Spaß gemacht
weil es dann wirklich herausfordern
würde und
für meinen Shelter war es nicht ganz so
geil das muss ich dann umziehen ich
glaube an Tag drei oder vier aber nicht
zuletzt halt eben auch durch die
Gezeiten trotzdem diese Gewitter die
haben halt so ein Ambiente gegeben von
Survival und ja überleben das war
richtig gut was war dein persönlich
größtes Problem in den sieben Tagen mein
größtes Problem war tatsächlich mit
Misserfolgen umzugehen ich hatte zum
Beispiel einen Feuerstahl dabei der hat
die ersten drei Tage gar nicht
funktioniert ich habe keinen Feierabend
bekommen was mich so gefrustet hat weil
ich war in Deutschland ich habe geübt
mit trockenem Gras mit allen möglichen
und selbst mit den Kindern mit denen
nichts geübt habe als immer problemlos
funktioniert gar kein Problem jetzt bin
ich dort gestanden hat vier Stunden lang
versucht und es hat einfach nicht
geklappt das war sehr frustrierend aber
insgesamt
war das dann auch irgendwann so ein
Punkt wo ich gesagt habe okay [ __ ] it
geht weiter und
dann war das auch irgendwann okay aber
dieser dieser Umgang mit Misserfolg war
das was mir am meisten zu schaffen
gemacht hat auch in dem Bezug dass zum
Beispiel Feuerstahl dann am Tag 5 ja von
den Wellen mitgerissen wurde und was
nimmst du Positives aus der Woche mit ja
also die positiven Sachen sind natürlich
mal wirklich alleine zu sein in der
Natur das ist atemberaubend du hast
irgendwie so viele Eindrücke und
gleichzeitig auch so wenige das ist
wirklich das ist so ein Erlebnis ich
glaube das haben ganz ganz wenige Leute
und dafür bin ich halt unglaublich
dankbar was soll ich dazu sagen das ist
ähm deswegen nehme ich auf jeden Fall
mit dann dieses persönliche Wachstum
dass man dadurch auch mitmacht definitiv
also man lernt Sachen über sich selbst
kennen das hört sich jetzt so ein
bisschen psychot hat mäßig an aber ist
krass also wenn man mal wirklich Zeit
hat sich mit sich selbst zu beschäftigen
und halt ja auch Zeit hat über Dinge
nachzudenken die im Alltag nicht so die
Zeit finden ist geil richtig geil gab es
für dich in diesen sieben Tagen mal im
Moment an dem du ernsthaft überlegt hast
den Knopf zu drücken und dich abholen zu
lassen der Moment an dem ich ganz safe
abbrechen wollte war tatsächlich ein Tag
drei als es wirklich geschüttet hat und
da hast du gemerkt okay jetzt geht's
nicht irgendwie so ein Dschungel Urlaub
oder so ein Strandurlaub sondern es geht
Strom zu kämpfen zu arbeiten zu kämpfen
du hast kein Essen du hast trinken aus
einer Quelle im Urwald das ist nicht
ganz so geil und vielleicht auch nicht
ganz so bekömmlich für den Magen wer
weiß und da habe ich halt gemerkt so
okay das ist nicht so leicht wie es mir
vorgestellt habe sondern deutlich
deutlich krasser und noch alles worauf
ich mich vorbereitet hatte Vorbereitung
war war für den Müll im Endeffekt ist
genau deswegen es kam alles anders und
da hatte ich dann die ersten struggles
okay möchte ich abbrechen aber der Wille
durchzuziehen war viel zu krass und ich
hätte niemals diesen gelben Knopf
gedrückt komme sehr starke Leistung du
hattest ja glücklicherweise ein paar
Gegenstände dabei welchen hattest du
aber nicht dabei den du gut hättest
gebrauchen können also die Gegenstand
zwar von mir war tatsächlich bin ich
persönlich gut aber dadurch dass ich
kein Feuer an hatte bringt dir auch der
Topf nichts und ja dadurch sind zwei von
drei Gegenständen schon mal hinfällig
wenn ich noch einen weiteren mitgenommen
hätte wäre es vielleicht der
Wasserfilter gewesen oder das
Moskitonetz je nachdem was er jetzt
ausgetauscht werden würde oder halt eben
auch nicht
aber so Moskitonetz wäre richtig geil
gewesen sag ich ganz ehrlich weil die
Moskitos sie haben einen aufgefressen
auch die Sandfliegen die wollten einen
einfach töten das war unglaublich ihr
habt eine Menge durchmachen müssen
würdest du deinen besten Freunden so
eine Erfahrung guten Gewissens empfehlen
oder Wünschen sofort also ganz ohne zu
zögern würde ich sagen ey mach doch
einfach was hast Du zu verlieren du
lernst was über dich selbst du lernst ob
du so eine Extremsituation gewachsen
bist das ist extrem geil also das mal
gemacht zu haben ist wirklich ein
unglaubliches unglaubliches Privileg
deswegen sofort Hammer dann herzlichen
Glückwunsch fürs Durchhalten und viel
Spaß zurück in der Zivilisation danke
dir danke danke danke
[Musik]